yeah hi I'm your field I'm founder of a
nonprofit organization called National
Social Entrepreneurship forum I'm here
to participate for the indian economic
summit which is being hosted by world
economic forum I am I have been kind of
attending a lot of sessions in last two
days and the theme of this year's
Leadership Summit is how we can link
leadership with livelihoods which is one
of the important challenges in India is
going through at the current state so
looking back in last few days there has
been a lot of discussion on how we can
create local opportunities for some of
the local challenges which India is
facing in different parts of the country
there has been a big discussion on how
diversity which is the strength of India
is also a challenge and how we can
reconcile love these regional interests
and how we can take forward the growth
in a very holistic manner in terms of
galvanizing collective efforts and not
just some kind of individual efforts so
it was a great experience and I really
enjoyed interacting with a lot of
thought leaders knowing about their
ideas how they want to kind of take
India's growth story forward and some of
these learnings I wish to take forward
and through my own work and kind of
addressing some of the key challenges
thank you